mais le roi 500 habitants ici le dernier
commerce une boulangerie a fermé en 2016
des clémentines nous emmener combien
monsieur depuis un an et demi on peut à
nouveau faire ses courses ici à la
manoeuvre dany un enfant du pays avec
une vingtaine d'habitants il a d'abord
chercher de l'argent pour financer le
projet une subvention du conseil
régional des dons et un prêt bancaire
plus tard tout est devenu possible c'est
des bungalows qu'on a acheté d'occasion
et il a fallu les transformer les isoler
les métronomes donc là il ya toute une
équipe de bénévoles les copains les îles
sont mis au boulot ça a duré deux ans et
pendant deux ans ils ont tous mis à
propres et pour en finir à ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui cette épicerie pour les
habitants du village cela change tout
notamment pour marie josée qui vient
souvent ici les chansons pas tout jeune
et puis même pour qui pour conduire moi
je vois j'ai des problèmes de vue ben je
ne conduis plus heureusement j'ai mon
mari mais sinon si on est tout seul on
est là on est bloqué mais le roi ici les
clients achètent des fruits des légumes
des pâtes ou des yaourts en majorité ce
sont des produits locaux de qualité mais
ce n'est pas seulement pour cela qu'ils
viennent rencontrer les gens ont pu
faire connaissance et puis ça le petit
village et bien ça sarvi ça me fait
grand plaisir de venir plus tôt dépenser
mon argent ici plutôt que dans la grande
surface du coin l'épicerie associative
tourne grâce aux bénévoles ils n'étaient
pas commerçants ils le sont devenus
document m'intéresse une bande de
copains et de copines
se retrouver déjà plusieurs fois par
semaine ensemble et surtout faire vivre
le village et tous ensemble arriver à
quelque chose un challenge qu'on s'est
fixés au départ et je pense qu'on y
arrive c'est notre force c'est ça c'est
l'idée d'avoir créé un truc ensemble et
montrer qu ensemble on peut faire des
belles choses sans être obligés
d'attendre toujours que ça tombe du ciel
cette année le chiffre d'affaires
devrait approcher les 120000 euros un
beau succès qui permet de continuer l
aventure d'embaucher un salarié est même
peut-être d'ouvrir un drive